اهلا بكم مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
للاشتباكات في السودان القتال مستمر في
اول ايام العيد الجديد دعوه لهدنا تمتد
ثلاثه ايام اعلن عنها الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اعلنوا موافقتهما عليها المفترض ان
تبدا الهدنه الان في هذه اللحظات سبق هذه
التطورات بيانات واتهامات متبادله ومقاطع
فيديو ينشرها الطرفان لاثبات
سيطرتهما على مناطق او مراكز في الخرطوم
باجزائها الثلاثه حلول عيد الفطر لم يمنع
من تواصل المعارك في العاصمه ونواحيها حيث
يشتد القتال في العديد من النقاط الساخنه
نتعرف على ابرزها
[موسيقى]
في العيد في السودان فدوي المدافع لا يزال
يصدح في مختلف ارجاء الخرطوم ونواحيها
خارطه المعارك تتغير بشكل مستمر في ظل
تغير المعطيات على ارض الميدان وبشكل عام
فان الاقتتال لا يزال متمركزا فيما يسمى
بالعاصمه المثلثه والمقصود بها الخرطوم
المدينه والخرطوم بحري او الخرطوم شمال
الى جانب ام درمان في الخرطوم المدينه فان
المعركه الدائره في النقاط الساخنه انتقلت
الى محيطها والحديث هنا عن مطار الخرطوم
ومقر القياده العامه فضلا عن القصر
الجمهوري فاذا كانت قوات الجيش قد نجحت في
وقت سابق في السيطره على المطار نفسه فان
الاقتتال انتشر في محيطه الشيء ذاته في
مقر القياده العامه الذي يشهد محيطه معارك
داريه اما في القصر الجمهوري فان
الاشتباكات مستمره بين الطرفين من اجل
سيطره على المبنى عمليه الكر والفر بين
الجانبين ادت الانتقال لاقتتال الى مناطق
واحياء ايضا ابرزها تلك الدائره على
امتداد شارع الستين في الجزء الشمالي
الشرقي للعاصمه وفي ام درمان وبينما توقف
الاغتال حول محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
شهد شمال المدينه اقتتالا عنيفا بين
الجانبين وتحديدا في جبل السركاب معركه
انتهت بسيطره قوات الجيش على قاعده عسكريه
كانت تابعه لقوات الدعم وفي الخرطوم بحري
فان ابرز الاشتباكات تدور حول معسكر
المظلات الذي تسيطر عليه قوات الدعم
السريعه وفضلا عن النقاط الساخنه للاقتتال
فان الجيش دشن عمليات تمشيط واسعه حيث
جابت دوريات مشاه عده احياء في العاصمه
ونواحيها وسام الذهبي العربيه
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم اللواء بابكر
ابراهيم احمد الخبير العسكري ولواء السابق
في القوات الجويه اهلا بكم لواء بابكر وكل
عام وانتم بالف خير نود ان نفهم منك كيف
ولدت هذه الهدنه اليوم كان هناك دعوه من
قبل قوات الدعم السريع لهدنا رفضها الجيش
ثم عاد واكد انه يوافق على هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام من غير شروط هل لديكم اي
معلومات حول تفاصيل هذه الهدنه هل هناك
ضمانات لاستمرارها من يقف خلفها
وفرص نجاحها
لواء بابكر تسمعني
لا انا معاك عادل سيدي احمد معاك عادل
سيدي احمد صحفي
عادل سيد احمد طيب
بدايه ونحن نتحدث عن بدء تطبيق هذه الهدنه
اين تتواجد انت الان وهل لك ان تؤكد لنا
ما اذا كانت هذه الهدنه قد دخلت بالفعل
حيز التنفيذ ام ان الاشتباكات ما زالت
مستمره في الخرطوم
مساء الخير كل عام وانتم بخير وشعب
السودان ان شاء الله دائما بخير على ان
يعود العيد علينا بالامن والسلام باذن
الله لا توجد على الارض هدنه اطلاقا نحن
سكان الخرطوم جنوب منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى هذا ظللنا نسمع دويا انفجارات
كبيره جدا ومعارك ضاريه
وتعززت هذه المعارك المعارك منذ ساعات
الصباح المتاخر يعني بعد الساعه العاشره
صباحا حيث كان واضح ان هناك
تمشيط بشكل واسع تقوم به القوات المسلحه
في منطقه الخرطوم جنوب والسبب في ذلك ان
بعض عربات الدعم التي يعني خرجت من مناطق
فقط اسمح لي انظرني على المقاطعه لكن يعني
دعني اشير الى بعض الاخبار العاجله مندوبه
امريكا للامم المتحده تقول الوضع
بالسوداني يتدهور باستمرار ولا مجال
لاضاعه الوقت
واكدت ودعت لتحرك فوري لمجلس الامن لدعم
وقف اطلاق النار بالسودان اذا هذه
دعوات من مندوبه امريكا لدى الامم المتحده
لتعزيز والبناء على وقف اطلاق النار الذي
تمت الموافقه عليه من قبل الطرفين والذي
تؤكد لنا سيد عادل سيد الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي من الخرطوم بانه الى الان لم يدخل
حيز التنفيذ
نعم كما اسلفت لك لا يوجد اصلا لا توجد
هودن على الارض
لان صوت
الدعوه للهدنه هو صوت عالي من قبل الدعم
السريع من جانب القوات المسلحه لا توجد
هنا خاصه ان القوات المسلحه تقول انها
تملك معلومات مؤكده ان الدعم السريع يريد
ان يستفيد من فتره الهدنه كي يلتقط انفاس
ولكنه وافق على كل حال
انضم الينا الان الخبير العسكري والرواء
السابق في القوات البحريه اهلا بكم لواء
بابكر وكل عام وانتم بالف خير ما معلوماتك
حول ظروف وملابسات موافقه الجيش بعد ان
رفض هذه الهدنه التي دعت لها قوات الدعم
السريع اليوم وهل هناك ضمانات لها
اول حاجه الدويه وليس البحريه
اولا كما قال متحدثك حتى في الفترات
السابقه بتاعت وقف اطلاق النار تعلم ان
المنظومه المنظومه السيطره لدى
مهاره تماما
ترى ليس هنالك حتى اتصال بين كل عربيه
تاتشر وعربيه تاتشر فكيف عمليا يمكن ان
ترسل اشارات ان هنالك وقفي نار هذا عمليا
غير ممكن لا نمره واحد نمره اثنين كلنا
نسعى لان يعود الهدوء ويتعود الطمانينه
الخيار الثاني
اسمح لي على المقاطعه تنتهي المعركه تقصد
انه يعني ان يحسم الجيش هذه المعركه
لصالحه ويخرج قوات الدعم السريع من
الخرطوم هذا ما تقصده
القوات القوات الدعم السريع انضربت الليله
كلها طلعت خارج الخرطوم القوات المسلحه
فاتحه ممر للاخلاء للهروب وفعلا هربت هذه
الغوات
لكن يعني انت تتحدث انت تتحدث عن هذا
الامر اذا كان واقع الحال بان قوات الدعم
السريع يعني اخلت مواقعها كيف تفسر موافقه
الجيش اليوم رسميا على الدخول في هدنه
لثلاثه ايام وكيف تفسرون الصور التي
نشرتها قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القياده
العامه وايضا من وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
وايضا من داخل هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
والاشتباكات التي بقيت مستمره طوال اليوم
كلام سياسي كلام عاطفي اتكلم عن الواقع
تحدثتم على الهدى في المراه المرتين
السابقه وما كان في اناديك الخ احسن من
الهدنه الخيار الاحسن من الهجره بالنسبه
للمراحل الانسانيه
الخرطوم تحتاج لمساعدات خارجيه وبالتالي
انا الان كنت بتكلم عن المرحله الثانيه
مرحله فتح الاجواء هي الاساس الاحسن من
لكي لكي نرتب النقاط التي نتحدث عنها لواء
بابكر انا اتحدث عن اعلان رسمي من قبل
الجيش السوداني اكد فيه موافقته على هدنه
تستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام خلال ايام العيد
سالتك ما معلوماتك عن ظروف وملابسات هذه
الهدنه وما اذا كان هناك ضمانات لتطبيقها
وفرص نجاحها
انا ما كلمتك قلت لك اساسا القوات الدعم
السريعه البسيطه الموجوده داخل العاصمه لا
تسمع كلامك ولا تسمع قيادات وليس لديها
شبكه اتصالات مع غيادات هؤلاء
يعملونكم مجموعات مجموعه موجوده في المكان
الفلاني تتصرف
تلقاء نفسها الجيش عاده يشتبك معهم هم
خروقاتهم بالليل 100% من 100% المعلومه
اللي عندك وعندي
وعند قيادتهم لم تصل اليهم هذا كلامه يعني
بالنسبه لهم لا يعني هذا الامر يعود لهم
الان المعلومه تصل يعني لحظه بلحظه من
خلال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لم تعد حكرا
على احد على كل حال
تلفوناتهم مرصوده ومقطوعه انا اقول لك
الواقع وبكره نتكلم يعني ثاني انه لن تكون
هنالك وقف اطلاق النار الجيش كعادته لازم
يقول انا اذا كان الامر كذلك اذا كان
الامر كذلك قبل سته ايام عندما بدات هذه
الاشتباكات الكثير من المحللين العسكريين
والخبراء العسكريين قالوا بانه هذه
المعركه لن تستمر سوى ساعات او بضعه ايام
يومان او ثلاثه على الاكثر لكن مع
اقترابنا من الدخول في الاسبوع الاول يبدو
ان هذه المعركه
لم تحسم لاي طرف كل طرف يدعي ونستمع الان
الى اصوات الانفجارات ونحن نتحدث معك كل
طرف يدعي انه سيطره على مكان ثم ياتي
الطرف الاخر
ويبط صور تؤكد بانه موجود في هذا المكان
وبالتالي لا شيء محسوم حتى الان باعتقادك
هل يمكن الاستهانه بقوات وقدرات قوات
الدعم السريع وتسليحه وخبراته وهل من
السهل اخراجه من الخرطوم
90% من القوات خرجت من الخرطين انا بديك
الاغواضع ليس الكلام بتاع الاعلام الوارد
90% وطلعت متبقي عشره في المئه
واماكن الممرات امنه
ولذلك من الناحيه الغربيه من الخرطوم
هنالك جيش فاتح وهم يخرجونه من هذه النسور
الصور اللي جاتكم النهار ده من شارع مدني
قاري ولايه الخرطوم وصلت الفكره وصلت فكره
شكرا جزيلا لك
معلومه احسن من كده
المعركه
مشهد نحو الاجواء ورتب
نا 20 ساعه وهذا هو نحن في الخلفيه حيث
انت معنا اصوات اطلاق النار والانفجارات
على كل حال شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من
الخرطوم اللواء ابو بكر ابراهيم احمد
الخبير العسكري واللواء السابق في القوات
الجويه لا ادري اذا كان عادل السيد احمد
معي على كل حال سنعود سنعود له ارجو ان
تتفضل البقاء معي ساعود لك لكن كاميرا
العربيه كانت اول وسيله اعلاميه تتمكن من
تصوير قاعده للدعم السريع في منطقه جبل
سركاب شمال ام درمان وكانت قوات الجيش
السوداني سيطرت على القاعده قبل ايام
نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صداقه العقدين بين البرهان وحميدتي لم
تنتصر على خلافهما على السلطه تصدعات عده
بدات منذ عام 2000 2021 زادها اتساعا
قرروا دمج قوه دعم سريع بالجيش ماذا فعل
العلاقه للانهيار
20 عاما قضاياها رفيقي درب وسلاح خندق
واحد جمع الضابطين اللذين عمل جنبا الى
جنب في ميادين القتال قبل ان يخرق صمت
المماطله بالاتفاق رصاص اوقع وحده الصف
وارهق صداقه امتدت لعقدين من الزمن
ابن باديه بسيط
نشاته في اغاص السودان كل منهما يتحذر من
مدرسه قتاليه مغيره صرامه عسكريه وتمرس
بمطارده الحركات المسلحه جمعت بينهما
ضرورات مرحليه تتقاطع مع ظروف حرب دارفور
عام 2003 فهناك كان اللقاء الاول بين عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان دقلو حينها
كان البرهان ضابطا بسلاح المشاته في مقاد
احمدتي عشرات المسلحين لحمايه الاهالي
وقوافل لتجارتهم هل تقاسم مهامه وذخيره
صعدت بعدها العلاقه تدريجيا وان عن بعد
قبل ان يدور الزمن ويعيدهما لصداره المشهد
عام 2019
تحالف عسكري سياسي هذه المره بهدف اسقاط
حكم البشير تحت ضغط الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
ليمتطيا معا صهوه فتره انتقاليه كان يؤمل
منها قياده البلاد نحو الديمقراطيه
مجلس عسكري له اخر عرف بمجلس السياده
الانتقالي تراسهما تباعا البرهان منتقيا
في كل مره صديقه للنيابه عنه
هذه العلاقه ظلت خاليه من التشويش لحين
اصطدامها بحائط رمي المسؤوليه عن فض
اعتصام القياده عام 2019
فبرزت شروخ داخل المكون العسكري تلملمت
على الاقل ظاهريا احمدتي اي دامه وصف
بانقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر ثم
تاسف عنه وامتعض من اعاده قائد الجيش
لعناصر النظام السابق للسلطه واتسعت
الفجوه اكثر مع توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي
والخلاف على الجداول الزمنيه لدمج قوات
الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه خلاف عجزت
مسيره الشراكه الطويله عن احتوائه وبين
العشاء الاول في دارفور والعشاء الاخير في
الخرطومه
ذهبت القضيه مع محاوله الاسراع بتذويب
الدعم السريع داخل الجيش بصفه نهائيه
وتنضم الينا من القاهره الدكتوره اماني
الطويل مديره البرنامج الافريقي في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات اهلا بك دكتوره اماني
دكتوره كيف تقرئين تطورات الاوضاع فيما
يتعلق الان بهذه الهدنه منذ الصباح والان
الدعم السريع
عرضهن لثلاثه ايام بمناسبه العيد رفضها
الجيش ثم عاد الجيش قبل نحو ساعه او ساعه
ونصف ووافق على هذه الهدنه دون شروط بعد
ان اشترط في السابق خروج قوات الدعم
السريع خارج الخرطوم باعتقادك هل هناك اي
ضغوط مورست على الجانبين لتنفيذ هذه
الهدنه
طيب يعني هذا السؤال
كان الدكتور لكن الدكتوره فقدنا الاتصال
بها على كل حال ينضم الينا سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم لاطلاعنا على ما
اذا كان هناك التزام بهذه الهدنه التي كان
من المفترض ان تدخل حيز التنفيذ قبل نحو
18 دقيقه سالم
وهناك التزام في مناطق متعدده من ولايه
الخرطوم على بعض
يعني سمعني بعض الاعلام مختلفه
النظر في الايام الماضيه وحتى السابقه
كذلك وربما تكون حتى للحظه هي الاقل
حتى هذه اللحظه مناطق ايضا في ولايه
الخرطوم تبدو فيها الحركه الطبيعيه الى حد
بالنسبه للمواطنين ونتحدث عن مناطق في
مدينه بحري
من مدينه الخرطوم اما بقيه المناطق وهي
قليله جدا كذلك من ام درمان ومتوسطه الى
حد ما في بحري وكثير جدا في الخرطوم
حركه فيها
تكون تبدو غير موجوده اصلا
هذا بالنسبه للحركه في ارطغرل والشوارع
محل
مناطق اخرى توجد بها محلات تجاريه يعني
اعمل في هذه اللح
ظه الان هناك انباء عن التزام نسبي كما
تتحدث وتنقل لنا في بعض مناطق الخرطوم لكن
هل تم تسجيل اي ردود فعل الى جانب يعني
هذه الاعلانات العسكريه من الاطراف
السياسيه المدنيه وهل هناك جهود لربما
البناء على هذه الهدنه وتقديم ضمانات
لاستمرارها من قبل الاطراف المدنيه وايضا
من يقفون خلف المكونين العسكريين
نعم بالنسبه للاطراف الاخرى حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تصدر بيانات متعلقه بهذه سوى
البيانات التي كانت من قبل التي تحدثت عن
هذه الفتنه وانها تستمر مثل ايام وانها
لايام عيد مبارك وبالاضافه الى انه متحدث
وعلى انها يمكن البناء عليها كذلك
قدمت هذه المبادره لكن يبقى السؤال في مدى
قدره الجانبين معانا
فرض البطاله وخاصه امام المطالب المتباعده
جدا بين الطرفين
امر الحوار ربما يكون عسيرا هذا عبصا على
ان القوات المسلحه الماليه كانت قد قررت
في اكثر من مره لانها ماضيه في هذه
العمليه لحسم التسلطات وان هذا خروجا على
نفسه قانون القوات المسلحه وانها لن تسمح
بان يكون هنالك اختراق لقانون القوات
المسلحه السودانيه طيب كيف انعكس هذا
الهدوء النسبي اليوم مقارنه بالايام
السابقه السادس ايام اشتباكات على طبيعه
الحياه في العاصمه السودانيه خصوصا في اول
ايام عيد الفطر
نعم
كذلك في انه هنالك احياء في مدينه الخرطوم
لم ترى العيد حتى الان بحكم الاغلاق الذي
يعني يطبق على هذه الاحياء ايضا حركه
القوات في تلك المناطق بالاضافه الى تبادل
الاعير الناريه والمدافعين والخطيره
وهناك احياء اخرى شهدت اعياد الطويل
الطبيعيه كذلك والحركه فيها كذلك هل يمكن
ان تحدد لنا مناطق الساخنه في العاصمه
الخرطوم
المناطق الساخنه هي محيط القياده العامه
احياء الخرطوم ثلاثه وكذلك
العمارات بالاضافه الى بعد ذلك جبرا وكذلك
الدين وبعض الامتدادات في الصحافه لكن ليس
للصحافه باكملها لكن اجزاء من احياء
الصحابه اما في مدينه الشعبيه
وكذلك
حمد هذه المناطق وكفوري بالتحديد بشكل عام
لذلك من المناطق ايضا
كوبر ايضا شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه في الايام
الماضيه انظر ما محيط الادعوه التلفزيون
وكذلك المهندسين ومنطقه صالحه هذه ابرز
المناطق التي تشهد احتداما وهي يعني
حركتها
قد تكون الى حد ما صعبه لكن بقيه المناطق
من ولايه
اين تتواجد انت الان نسمع في الخلفيه وانت
تتحدث معنا اصوات انفجارات
[موسيقى]
عبر الصوره الموجوده في الشاشه
الذي انا فيه نعم نعم
نتمنى ان يبقى الوضع على ما هو عليه لديك
وفي كامل
العاصمه الخرطوم دعنا نستطلع الاجواء في
مروي في اول ايام العيد معا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي نزار كيف كان اول ايام العيد
في مدينه مروي التي قيل بان الجيش سيطر
عليها بالكامل وعلى القاعده الجويه
مدينه مروي العيد بدا فيها بالتهليل
وبالتكبير من قبل المصلين الذين خرجوا
ساجد وفي الميادين العامه وفي الساحات في
مروي وماديا وورها من مدن استعدادا لهذا
اليوم السعيد يوم العيد
على صعيد اخر القوات المسلحه قد الصلاه
العيد داخل مقر الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشاه
بحقوق الجهات التنفيذي ممثلا في والي
الولايه وفي القيادات السياسيه والتنفيذيه
التي
خصيصا من حاضره الولايه مدينه دنقله الى
مدينه مروي حيث كانت
مسرحابيه والاشتباكات والعمليات العسكريه
الجيش خلال هذه المناسبه وخلال المعايده
اكد على رسائل مهمه اول هذه الرسائل بانه
يمضي نحو سيطرته على هذه المنطقه
ايضا في رساله ثانيه لانه لا وجود اطلاقا
لقوات الدعم السريع داخل المحليه مروي
واكد في رساله ثالثه بانه سي
تعاطى متغيرات التي ستحدث خلال المرحله
المقبله سواء
تتعلق بوجود عناصر غير مرغوب فيها ويؤكد
ويقول اكثر من مره بان السيناريوهات محتمل
وانه على درجه من الاستعداد هذا الاستعداد
بدا قبل سبعه ايام وقبل ذلك وما زال
متواصلا يؤكد ايضا بانه يمتلك من الجاهزيه
والعتاد ما يمكنه من الحفاظ على كافه
المرافق الاستراتيجيه في هذه المنطقه
والحفاظ على امن وسلامه المواطنين ليس في
مروي وانما في عموم الولايه الشماليه هل
عدد خدمات الماء والكهرباء والانترنت بشكل
كامل الى المدينه
خدمات المياه خدمات الكهرباء خدمه
المستشفى يحط الان تعمل على كفاءه عاليه
لانه لا توجد اضرار كثيره لحقت بالمواطنين
واصابات من واقع ان العمليات والاشتباكات
العسكريه كانت محصوره فقط داخل حرم المطار
والقاعده العسكريه الطرق سالكه من الى
بقيه المدن دعني فقط اعلق على الصور التي
تلتقطها كاميرا العربيه
نزار من العاصمه الخرطوم
نستمع بين الفين والاخرى الى صوت متقطع
لاطلاق النار وبعض اصوات الانفجارات لكنها
مقارنه بما كان عليه الوضع صباح اليوم
وبعد الظهر اقل بكثير انخفضت وتيره هذه
الاشتباكات كما اكد لنا عادل سيد وايضا
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي من العاصمه
اصوات اطلاق نار متقطعه لكن لا نستمع الى
على كل حال دعونا نستمع الى ما يحدث في
الخرطوم
اذا اطلاق نار متقطع يبدو ان هناك جهود
تبذل لانجاح هذه الهدنه سالم لا ادري اذا
كنت معي ما زلت معي
[موسيقى]
طيب اذا نعود لك نزار بقداوي من مروي
كيف ينظر سكان مروي الى كل ما حدث يعني
الان نقترب من الدخول في الاسبوع الاول من
هذه الاشتباكات انطباعات الناس
وهل هناك اي موقف واضح لهم من المكونين
العسكريين
مواطن هذه المنطقه
تفاعلوا ايجابا مع السيطره التي احدثها
الجيش على المنطقه وعلى المطار
وخلال معايده
عديد الرسائل التي بعثت في بريد القوات
المسلحه السودانيه الجيش بانهم سنه لهذه
القوات بانهم يقفون مع هذه القوات
بان ما حدث في مروي يجب ان لا يحدث مره
اخرى وعلى الجيش ان يحكم السيطره على
مخارج هذه المحليه وان لا يسمح مره اخرى
بحدوث ما حدث خلال الاسبوع المنصرم
المواطنون ايضا يتفاعلون اجابه مع وجود
بعض العناصر
المصالحه والمصابين بطبيعه الحال في
المرافق الصحيه هم يقدمون وجبه الافطار
كان يوم الامس في رمضان وقدموا اليوم
عيديه ايضا وصلت قافله والمسانده تحتوي
على
وعينيه من مدينه تعبير عن وقفه الحكومه
والمواطنين وادارات اهليه وسكان هذه
المحليه والمنطقه مع القوات المسلحه ما
حدث خلف
جرحا في نفوس المواطنين لان هذه المنطقه
كانت معروفه بالامن بالسلام هي منطقه
سياحيه بامتياز تزار من قبل السودانيين
ومن قبل الاجانب يقولون بانها تعرضت لضربه
في امنها وفي سلامها وعلى الجيش الله
بدات منها القصه كامله يعني
نعم
خصوصا ان مروي كانت المنطقه التي بدات
منها او انطلقت منها شراره هذه الاشتباكات
نعم نعم هذه الشراره والمواطنين الصراحه
لم يكن يتوقعون اطلاقا انهم سيشهدون ما
شاهدوا لم يكن يتوقعون ولو في الخيال ان
مروي ستحلق فيها الطائرات الحربيه بان
مروي سيسمعون ويشاهدون بام العين المدفعيه
الثقيله وهي تضرب بقوه
اصوات المدافع ويستمعون الى اجهزه
الطائرات والمدفعيه الثقيله كل هذا شاهدوه
وهم على مقربه الامطار قليله من القاعده
العسكريه والبطائق الحربي هنا في مدينه
مروي لاحظنا ايضا من المشاهدات التي يجب
ان تنقل
حاله التعزيه التي
عديد المواطنين هنا في مدينه مروي
والزيارات الخاصه للاسر التي فقدت ابنائها
خلال الاش الدانيه خلال اليومين الماضيين
عديد الابناء من منطقه مروي وما جاورها من
قرى فقدوا خلال الاشتباكات الاخيره
المواطنين قدموا واجب العزاء لاسرهم
ودعوا لهم بالرحمه
والمغفره وكانت الاحاسيس احاسيس جياشه وسط
المواطنين وهم يقدمون هذه اللوحه
بعديده الاشارات الايجابيه وهم يقولون هذه
المدينه هي مدينه للوحده مدينه للسلام
ويجب ان تمضي على هذا النمط طيب هل لديك
اي معلومات حول طبيعه الوضع في باقي
المناطق في نيالا الاوبيض
وايضا في دارفور كيف هو الوضع وهل الحديث
عن هدنه في الخرطوم يمكن ان ينسحب على
باقي المناطق
لنبدا هذه الخارطه خارطه الاشتباكات
والعمليات العسكريه من الخرطوم كما تتابع
انت الان وعلى الصور
الاصوات المتقطعه محيط القياده منطقه وسط
الخرطوم منطقه جنوب الخرطوم التي قالت
اليها ايضا الصور والاعين باعتبارها ايضا
منطقه ساخنه المناطق التي تخرج من الخرطوم
صوب الولايات الجنوبيه والحديث هنا عن
ولايه وانتشار لسيارات الدعم السريع بحسب
شهود العيان هذا موقف شمال شمال كردفان
يوم الامس ايضا كانت
في حاله تعافي بعض
المسلحه التي خلفت عشرات الضحايا
والمصابين بعد اشتباكات حدثت بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع المسرح هذه العمل هل
هي تحديدا كان داخل سوق المدينه مدينه
الابيض هي من المدن الاقتصاديه الكبيره في
غرب السودان وفي شمال كوردوفان هي عصبه
الاقتصاد في منطقه كوردوفان يوم الامس
وامس الاول ضربت بقوه في هذه المنطقه
المواطنون الان بداوا يلتقطون انفاسهم بدو
يتنفسون الصعباء بعد
المشهد في الفاشر الان هنالك شبه هدنه
وشبه اجراءات تمت من قبل وادي الحياه
الرجل جمع اطراف الصراع وتحدث معهم ووضع
اجراءات تمنع حدوث اشتباكات بعد ان خلفت
ايضا الاشتباكات الضحايا ومصابين الان
الجيش يقول بانه يحكم على الامر ويبسط
سيطرته الفرقه السادسه عشر مشاه هنالك في
مدينه نيالا تتمركز في عدد من المواقع
الاستراتيجيه منعا
لايسل
هذا هو المشهد الان وهذه هي ابرز النقاط
يعني عمليه الرئيسي يتركز الان في الخرطوم
الهدوء يسود تقريبا باقي المناطق للحديث
عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من جنوب
الخرطوم الصحفي مدثر محمد احمد
سيد مدثر بدايه كل عام وانتم بالف خير
بدايه من خلال مقارنتك بسير الاشتباكات
منذ الصباح وحتى الان هل يمكن القول بانها
هدات نسبيا بعد ان دخل الهدنه التي تم
الاعلان عن بدء تنفيذها قبل 35 دقيقه حيز
التنفيذ
نعم كل عام وانتم بخير
بالفعل نحن في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم هذه
المنطقه شهدت منذ صباح اليوم هدوءا نسبيا
في الاحياء الواقعه في جنوب الخرطوم شهدت
هدوء نسبيا لم نسمع او لم يرد الينا وجود
اشتباكات في اي من هذه المناطق هذه
المناطق شهدت خلال ايام الماضيه وبالامس
مساء كانت هناك اشتباكات عنيفه في منطقه
الجنوب الخرطوم منطقه جبرا منطقه
ارض المعسكرات في سوبا منطقه السلمه منطقه
الازهري كانت قد شهدت يعني اشتباكات عنيفه
في المساء ولكن منذ صباح اليوم لم ترد
الينا او لم نسمع حتى هذه الاصوات التي
كانت ترد الينا لوجود اشتباكات
في في يعني طوله الصباح اليوم الظهيره
وحتى المساء بكل تاكيد مع دخول الهدنه حيث
التنفيذ ربما يعني
تذهب تذهب الهدوء الى يعني النسبيه في
الهدوء اكثر من منه الى النسبيه يعني
الاشتباك
واضح نحن نتابع في هذه الصوره صوره مباشره
من خلال الكاميرا العربيه
للعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وايضا صور
متفرقه من ام درمان والخرطوم اليوم ومروي
ايضا
سابقا لكن الان عيننا على ما يحدث في
الخرطوم يبدو ان الامور تتجه نحو الهدوء
النسبي شيئا فشيئا تتراجع حده الاشتباكات
ويتراجع صوت اطلاق الرصاص واصوات
الانفجارات نتمنى ان يبقى الوضع على ما هو
عليه يبدو ان هذه الهدنه قد تدخل بالفعل
حيز التنفيذ ويبدو ان هناك ربما جهودا
تبذل من قبل اطراف داخليه وخارجيه للحفاظ
على هذه الهدنه التي دعت لها قوات الدعم
السريع اليوم
ووافقت قوات الجيش على الدخول بها لثلاثه
ايام هي ثلاثه ايام تصادف ايام عيد الفطر
السعيد بعد سته ايام من الاشتباكات القويه
بين الطرفين وفشل الهدنه التي تم اعلانها
يوم امس والتي حدث بها الكثير من الخروقات
في سياق ذاته قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه في مقابله عن العربيه قال ان
الوضع في السودان خطير جدا ويهدد استقرار
المنطقه ودعت الخارجيه الفرنسيه لهدنه
ووقف اطلاق نار غير مشروط في السودان كما
اكدت الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها على تواصل
مستمر مع الشركاء بحثا عن مخرج من الازمه
في السودان ودعت الفرنسيين بالسودان الى
الالتزام والبقاء في منازلهم
وتنضم الينا من القاهره الدكتوره اماني
الطويل مديره البرنامج الافريقي في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات اهلا بك دكتوره تسمعيني
نعم اسمعك استاذ نبيل اهلا بكم بالمشاهدين
استاذ ابراهيم
زميلتي رشا نبيل على كل حال بدايه اود ان
استلم منك لتحليل حول ظروف وملابسات هذه
الهدنه هل تعتقدي بان اطرافا محليه او
دوليه ضغطت على المكونين العسكريين
لتطبيقها خصوصا ان استمعنا اليوم الى
تصريحات قويه من الخارجيه الفرنسيه وايضا
من مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه ومن البيت
الابيض تتحدث عن ضروره وقف اطلاق النار
لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب في السودان
يعني في تقديري ان العاملين معا قد يعني
ان هناك عاملان قد عمل من اجل ان تكون هذه
الهدنه الرابعه من نوعها تحظى بقدر من
التطبيق العامل الاول واعتقد انه العامل
الحاسم ان الجيش قد حقق تقدما ما في مدينه
الخرطوم وخصوصا في مقر القياده العامه او
حول القياده العامه وبالتالي قيمه هذا
الانجاز يدفع الجيش بشكل او باخر الى ان
يكون مستريح
في الوضع الميداني بالنسبه لقوات الدعم
السريع المساله الثانيه طبعا يمكن ان يكون
هناك استجابه للضغوط الدوليه المرتبطه
بضروره اجلاء الاجانب ولعلنا نذكر انه في
الهدنه الثانيه على ما اذكر هي الهدنه
التي استطاعت فيها مصر ان تجلي جنودها من
السودان عبر طائرات عسكريه وبالتالي
المجتمع الدولي يعني
والمقر الدبلوماسيه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
للدول تحتاج الى اخلاق وخصوصا ان الجانب
الامريكي في غايه القلق بشان رعياه وبشان
البعثه الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
وكانت هناك محاوله لاجلائهم ولكنها قد
ارجات واظن ان اجلائهم سوف يكون في هذه
الهدنه وخصوصا ايضا بانه الولايات المتحده
اعلنت مقتل امريكي خلال هذا الاشتباكات
وايضا كان هناك اعلانات عن مقتل موظفين
امميين وبالتالي الامور الان تغيرت
الولايات المتحده لم تكن قررت او حسمت
امرها حيال اجلاء الرعايه ام لا لكن فكره
ان تقرر هذه البعثات اجلاء رعاياها هل تشي
بان الامور لا تتجه الى العوده الى طاوله
الحوار وان هذه الدول لديها معلومات
وتقييمات استخبارات يه بان الامور تتجه
الى مزيد من التصعيد
ليس بالضروره مزيد من التصعيد طبعا هذه
المعلومات لابد ان تكون موجوده وهذه
البعثات لديها ادوات في يعني بلوره تقدير
الموقف الميداني والعسكري وخصوصا انه على
الارض يعني موجودين في الخرطوم
لكن ربما يكون المساله ان الحسم سوف يعني
تطول مدته وانه غير واضح
هذا الحسم ليس بالضروره التصعيد ولكن ربما
يعني استمرار الاشتباكات التي نراها حاليا
في الخرطومه وبالتالي تهديد حيوات افراد
البعثه الدبلوماسيه والرعايه الاجانب طيب
الان اذا ما تحدثنا عن هذه الهدنه
ونجحت هذه الهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
باعتقادك هل يمكن البناء عليها
للتوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار والعوده
من جديد الى طاوله المفاوضات ام لا يعني
ما حدث من مواجهات وتصريحات وكل هذا القتل
وقد يمنع الطرفين من الحديث مجددا برايك
الى اي مدى من المهم البناء على هذه
الهدنه ان نجحت
يعني
طبعا مهم البناء على هذه الهدنه لكن شروط
البناء عليها تتطلب تقديم مشروع بشكل معين
سواء من جهه داخليه او خارجيه مشروع تفوضي
للاطراف
يتعلق بعدد من النقاط المرتبطه بالاجلاء
عن مناطق مثلا تواجد المدنيين عدم تحول
هذه يعني الكف عن ان تكون هذه الاشتباكات
هي نوع من انواع حرب المدن
تثبيت الموقف العسكري عند
على ما هو عليه يعني التزام الاطراف في
هذه المساله اتصور اذا تم تقديم ورقه من
هذا النوع للطرفين سواء من جهه داخليه او
خارجيه ربما نستطيع البناء على هذه الهدنه
اما اذا كانت الهدنه هدفها الاساسي
والرئيسي هو يعني
توفير فتره المدنيين كانوا يستطيعوا ان
يتحركوا يحصل على المؤن او يدفنوا الشهداء
او غير ذلك فلا اعتقد انه يمكن البناء على
هذه الهدنه وتحولها مثلا الى مشروع وقف
اطلاق النار وقف الاطلاق النار وبالتالي
تحول كل ذلك الى
يعني حاله تفاعليه بين الاطراف ربما تكون
بوجود وسطات داخليه او خارجيه يعني ربما
من المبكر ان نقول هذا اليوم قدامنا 48
ساعه او مع نهايه الهدنه للحديث حول هذه
النقاط لكن على الاقل نختبر هذه الهدنه في
خلال الساعات القادمه ومدى مصداقيه
الاطراف في الالتزام بها جيد انا اشكرك
على كل هذه المعلومات والتحليل دكتوره
اماني الطويل مديره البرنامج الافريقي في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات كنت معنا مباشره من
القاهره
ضجيج اليات العسكر لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنالين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق رصاصه الاولى
طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات تنازلات
بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل التنافس بينهما
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وفيما كانت
الالات العسكريه المتنافسه تستعد للقتال
تدفقت القوات بهدوء على معسكرات الجيش
المتنافسه في جميع انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم
بدايه الخلاف وبحسب الصحيفه خرجت من قلق
حمد المتمثل باختراق الجيش من قبل موالينا
للنظام السابق فيما بدات المخابرات
العسكريه بقياده البرهان في اخبار
المسؤولين الاجانب بان حمد حاول سرا
استيراد طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من
تركيا لتعزيز قوته فالخلافات لوحدت حتى
بين افراد الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاملوا كقوتين متنافستان وليس منسجمتين
ضمن نفس الدوله لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم
الخلاف اكثر محاوله الاتفاق على دمج
القوتين في جيش واحد خصوصا ان هذه العمليه
ستخرج حمدتي الخاسر الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوثه الامريكي جفيف حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
قالت مجموعه الازمات الدوليه في بيان الله
ان الاشتباكات الحاليه في السودان قد
تتطور الى حرب اهليه في حال لم يتوقف
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع كما دعت المنظمه البلدان المجاوره
للسودان وكل ما لديه علاقه وثيقه مع
البرهان واحمدتي بان يتم التواصل معهما
لايجاد حل مناسب ووقف الاشتباكات بين
القوتين
قالت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود دوليه ان
فريقها الطبي لا يمكنه ادخال اي امدادات
طبيه اضافيه الى السودان في ظل الاشتباكات
الحاليه محذره من انه اذا لم يتغير الوضع
في المنطقه فسيكون هناك المزيد من الخسائر
في الارواح كما اشارت المنظمه في بيان لها
الى ان الامدادات التي تقدمها في مستشفى
الفاشر ستكفي فقط لثلاثه اسابيع اضافيه في
حاله عدم ادخال اي امدادات جديده الى
المستشفى
لا هدنه تصمد ولا عيد يشفع فاللغه الخصوم
تحتد اكثر ويكثر الرصاص يسمع صداه هنا
يسقط مدنيون ويتداعى قطاع باكمله قتلى
وجرحى بالعشرات اكثر من 600 قتيل ومئات
الجرح بحسب وزاره الصحه السودانيه اعداد
تضغط على قطاع طبي على وشك الانهيار
خروج متواليه لعدد من المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه وايضا هنالك عدد من المستشفيات
الاخرى ايضا هي على حافه الاغلاق وزاره
الصحه السودانيه قالت
مستشفيات تعمل بكامل طاقتها في الخرطوم
وبينت ان عشره مستشفيات حكوميه خرجت عن
الخدمه في العاصمه نقابه الاطباء قالت ان
14 مستشفى تعرضت للقصف في البلاد بينما
يعملون نحو 23 مستشفى بشكل جزئي لكنها
مهدده بالاغلاق
الط
بيه خصوص
ا الطبيه
وفي ظل ظروف صعبه تعمل منظمات دوليه
واماميه لدعم القطاع الطبي المنهك لكن
القتال يعقد اي مسعا لذلك منظمه اطباء بلا
حدود قالت ان فريقها الطبي لم يتمكن من
ادخال امدادات طبيه اضافيه الى السودان
المنظمه اشارت الى ان الامدادات في مستشفى
الفاشر مثلا تكفي لثلاثه اسابيع فقط
اذا ايضا في الاخبار العاجله الخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول على الامريكيين الا
يتوقعوا عمليه منسقه
للاجلاء من السودان موقف امريكي جديد حيال
هذه العمليه ربما نتحدث بمزيد من التفصيل
عن هذا الموضوع مع مراسل العربيه في
واشنطن بعد قليل لكن الان مزيد من المواقف
الدوليه حيال ما يحدث في السودان حيث قال
وزير الخارجيه الاسباني حسين مانويل في
مؤتمر صحفي في برلين ان الطائرات العسكريه
الاسبانيه في وضع الاستعداد وجاهزه لاجلاء
حوالي 60 مواطنا اسبانيا ونحو 20 مدنيا من
دول اخرى من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وسط صراع مسلح هناك
وزاره الخارجيه المصريه قالت انها على
تواصل مستمر مع سلطات السودانيه لتسهيل
عوده مواطنيها عبر المنافذ البريه في
السودان دون عوائق واضافه الخارجيه في
بيان لها نشرته على فيسبوك بانها تواصل من
خلال بعثاتها في السودان بدله كافه الجهود
والقيام بالاتصالات اللازمه لمتابعه اوضاع
الجاليه المصريه في البلاد خلال الازمه
والتعاطي السريع معها تبعا للمستجدات
اكد جونكر بمتحدث باسمنا الامن القومي في
البيت الابيض ان القوات المسلحه الامريكيه
تتابع الاستعدادات من اجل جاهزيه اي اجلاء
من الخرطوم موضحا ان الاجلاء سيشمل الجميع
بشكل خاص الدبلوماسيه مشددا ان الاعتداء
على الطاقم الدبلوماسي امر غير مقبول على
الاطلاق محتملا استماريه اطلاق النار
والاشتباكات بين الطرفين المتصارعين دون
ان يهدا الوضع
وكانت الخارجيه الامريكيه اعلنت عن مقتل
الامريكيه خلال الاشتباكات القائمه بين
قوات الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه واوضح المتحدث باسم الوزاره
بانه لم يتم الكشف بعد عن اسم الضحيه
وجنسها مشيرا الى انه لا توجد تفاصيل
اضافيه حول ملابسات الحادثه هذا واعلنت
الخارجيه الامريكيه في وقت سابق عن وجود
حوالي 16 الف امريكي في الاراضي السودانيه
وانضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل العربيه في
ارغانم اهلا بك لو تعطينا مزيد من
التفاصيل حول اخر مواقف الخارجيه
الامريكيه وايضا البيت الابيض حيال ما
يحدث في السودان
اولا ليس هناك بعد اي قرار باجراء عمليه
الاجلاء من السودان السبب الاول هو ان
الوضع على الارض بحسب تقدير البيت الابيض
هو وضع سيء ولا يمكن اجراء عمليه الاجلاء
في ظل هذه الاوضاع طبعا هكذا عندما تحدث
الى الصحفيين قبل قليل الى ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على اتصال مع الاطراف
وهي تدعوهم لوقفا لاطلاق النار لكنه اشار
ايضا الى ان وقفه اطلاق النار لا يستمر
حتى هذه الساعه قبل قليل ايضا بالاضافه
الى وزاره الخارجيه اوضحت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض كريم جانبير الى ان عمليه
الاجلاء من افغانستان كانت استثناء وليست
هي القاعده وكانت بهذا المعنى تريد
الاشاره الى ان عمليه الاجلاء لو حصلت سوف
تكون بالاولويه الى الدبلوماسيين
والعاملين الرسميين من الامريكيين
الموجودين على الاراضي السودانيه ولكن لن
يشمل ذلك كل الامريكيين الموجودين على
الاراضي السودانيه خصوصا وهذا تفسيرنا لما
كانت تقوله كريم لن يشمل مزدوجي الجنسيه
ولن نرى عمليه اجلاء واسعه كما شاهدناها
من كابول يعني نفهم من هذا الكلام بانه لا
نيه لدى واشنطن لاجلاء مواطنيها ودبلوم
بسبب الاوضاع
المحتدمه على الارض يعني لو توفرت الظروف
المناسبه ستقوم واشنطن باجلاء دبلوماسيين
تقوم بعمليه اجلاء الدبلوماسيين والرسميين
الذين يعملون لصالح البعثه الامريكيه
الموجوده في السودان ولكن ذلك لا يشمل
الامريكيين الاخرين الذين هم موجودون على
الاراضي السودانيه ولكن لا يعملون لمصلحه
الحكومه الامريكيه هل هناك معلومات حول
هويه او تكشفت معلومات حول هويه القتيل
الامريكي وجنسه وظروف وملابسات مقتله ولو
بشكل غير رسمي من خلال الصحف
وسائل التواصل في الولايات المتحده
حتى الان ليست لدي معلومات واضحه حول هذا
الموضوع نستطيع ان نقدمها
للمشاهدين الكرام ولكن من الواضح ان
الامريكيين غاضبون جدا حول هذا الموضوع
وكانوا حذروا في اتصالات مع
القيادات العسكريه الموجوده في الخرطوم من
باي شخص يعمل في البعثات الدبلوماسيه هل
هناك بين واشنطن والمكونان العسكريين
للتوصل لاتفاق نار وهل تقف الولايات
المتحده وراء موافقه الجيش حسب معلوماتكم
على الهدنه
وهي تدعو الى وقف لاطلاق النار وهي تريد
وقفا لاطلاق النار من الممكن ان يستديم
اولا تستتم الاوضاع وتتوقف الاشتباكات في
السودان وتعتبر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان الوضع هو وضع سيء وعنيف ويجب
ان يكون هناك وقف اطلاق نار مستمر
ليتمكنوا من القيام بعمليات الاجلاء شكرا
لك بيرغانم مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من
واشنط
ن
[موسيقى]
الان الى مجموعه من الاخبار حول العالم
ونبداها من وزير الدفاع الامريكيه لويد
اوستن الذي سعى الى تهدئه اي خلاف بين
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها بشان تسريب
الوثائق السريه من الولايات المتحده
اوستنغالا خلال اجتماع لوزاره الدفاع عقد
في قاعده رامشتاين الجويه في المانيا انه
ياخذ هذه القضيه على محمل الجد وسيواصل
العمل عن كثب مع حلفاء الولايات المتحده
وشركائها
اعلم ان الكثير منكم كان يتابع التقارير
قضيه تسريب الوثائق الحساسه الامريكيه
دققت في هذه القضيه بشكل جاد ونعمل عن قرب
مع الحلفاء والشركاء الذين اكدوا لنا
دعمهم الكامل لن تسمح باي محاولات للنيل
من وحدتنا
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان لها ان
الاجراءات والخطابات الاخيره من اوكرانيا
تظهر ان روسيا بحاجه الى مواصله العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا مؤكده ان
العمليه ستستمر حتى تستكمل اهدافها
المعلنه المتمثله في نزع السلاح والقضاء
على التهديدات للامن الروسي
قال الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي يان
سلتنبرغ ان مستقبل اوكرانيا سيكون عبر
انضمامها الى حلف شمال الاطلسي مؤكدا ان
حلفاء الناتو اجمعوا على ان تصبح اوكرانيا
عضوا في الحلم
قلت في كييف بالامس ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
يكمن في الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وكل حلفاء النيتو قد اجمعوا على ان تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو لكن يجب ان نركز
الان على كيفيه ضمان انتصار اوكرانيا في
الحرب ضد روسيا
حثة الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا على
الانسحاب من باخمت منذ يناير من العام
الماضي لعدم قدرتها على السيطره على وضع
المدينه بحسب صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه
نقلا عن وثائق البنتا المشربه وفق الصحيفه
اقدمت واشنطن على هذه النصيحه بعد ان كانت
تقدم الروسي ثابتا منذ نوفمبر وحينما لم
تستجب اوكرانيا لتلك التحذيرات قررت
البقاء اقترحت الوثائق السريه ان يتم
التخطيط لاحباط الروح المعنويه الروسيه
موصيه بشن هجمات بذخيره تقليديه محسنه ذات
استخدام مزدوج ومزيجا من قصف المدفعيه
وصواريخ ارض جو
افاد مراسل العربيه بان بولندا ودول بلطيق
تضغط من اجل استيراد الذخيره والصواريخ من
كوريا الجنوبيه لدعم اوكرانيا من جهته اكد
مصدر دبلوماسي اوروبي ان الدعم الاجنبي
لاوكرانيا يثير حفيظه فرنسا التي تعترض
على استيراد الذخيره والصواريخ من خارج
اوروبا لدعم اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان فرنسا
تقول انه يجب الاعتماد على صناعه الذخيره
والصواريخ الاوروبيه لدعم
مع استمرار الخلافات بين واشنطن وبيكين
حذرت الخرجه الصينيه من التدخل في شؤونها
وعلاقاتها الدوليه وقاره الخارجيه الصينيه
ان شراكه بين بكين وموسكو ليس لها حدود
وتاتي تصريحات الصينيه ردا على وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانيت يلن التي اتهمت
الصين بانها ليست جاده بشان انهاء الحرب
في اوكرانيا
التغطيه مشاهدينا مستمره على قناه العربيه
للاشتباكات في السودان لكن على راس الساعه
مع الزميله رشا نبيل تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والو والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات